Vegas baby what sorry mmm CES is in
Vegas this week so I'm getting all
excited we work for CBS no CES the
second hand gamechap no the consumer
electronic show takes place every year
the glitz the glamour the gambling the
gadgets gizmos so it's a show where big
electronics companies wave their
Willie's around and shop new tech right
yeah is there any gaming stuff well you
don't need gaming stuff when you got a
washing machine that can do two loads at
the same time yes okay that was gaming
stuff actual game announcements were
thin on the ground but everyone's
favorite pro skater came out of the
underground to announce a new game Tony
Hawk pop shoved it on to sony's press
conference to show off the 4k action cam
and mentioned that his new title will
board slide into our lives in 2015 that
last reference wasn't so good ah
kickflip McTwist as well as fancy camera
sony also revealed that the ps4 had sold
through 18.5 million units which is a
lot maybe they should have spent that
money on getting a better copy editor as
they've only gone and spelled view with
a u playstation view the cloud-based TV
broadcast and on-demand service is now
out of beta and will be coming to ps3
and ps4 in the first quarter of this
year before hitting iPads and other
stuff speaking of other stuff madcatz
announced a $300 transforming controller
that rolls out into different
configurations for your smartphones and
tablets the links also comes equipped to
the microphone keyboard and a cable to
put your little screen onto the big one
nvidia announced the Tegra x1 mobile
superchip the packs of 256 core GPU on
top of an eight-core central processing
unit the hell does that mean it gives up
one teraflop of computational power that
didn't answer my question which means
the chip is both powerful and energy
efficient enough to bring pc and console
grade graphics to handhelds like
smartphones finally the Angry Birds
we've all been waiting for graphics fans
can rejoice again as LG
announced that they'll be bringing out a
34 inch monitor which houses AMD's free
sync technology by better syncing the
display with the graphics card inside
your pc free sync reduces on screen
tearing and input lag for games in other
pc news steelseries revealed the apex
m800 mechanical keyboard where the keys
light up when you touch them the future
is now anything on VR well Samsung's
creamy music and video streaming service
milk will now deliver virtual reality
experiences movies and games to gear VR
which is a headset that you swap the
Galaxy Note 4 into even raises getting
in on the act with its open source VR
platform calling it the Android of
virtual reality oculus have also
announced that 2015 will be the year of
VR so maybe they're hinting at a release
date and what about 4k TVs surely they
were everywhere you know what's cooler
than 4k 1 billion dollars I mean 8k and
the washing machine can connect to Wi-Fi
so if you've got your phone out you can
monitor your cycle that's awful share
the load mr. Frodo and all that anyway
that's it for this week join us next
time for some more adventures in tech I
mean games you're all right
excuse me I'm sorry I'm sorry okay